annoncer la sanction c'est patrick
strzoda ça c'était pour le la suite du
1er mai donc j'ai été suspendu pendant
quinze jours
ok oui alors j'ai pu exposer mes
arguments à patrick strzoda qui les a
entendus
qui après a pris sa décision en tout cas
moi je sais patrick strzoda qui m'a
annoncé ma sanction
voilà et ensuite j'ai pu recevoir un
courrier aux d'un deuxième alors il ya
eu un premier entretien avec patrick
strzoda et après avec la chef du
personnel
madame patricia janin qui m'a remis un
courrier qui me fait signer et voilà
j'ai pris mes dispositions pour être
absent pendant les 15 jours qui arrivait
derrière et à ce moment là il n'a pas
été question de ce que on l'a qualifié
de rétrogradation alors la
rétrogradation est intervenu à mon
retour c'est dire quand je suis revenu
au bout de quinze jours j'ai été
convoqué et dans le bureau de patrick
strzoda et dans le bureau de françois
lisée village qui m'ont expliqué qu'en
fait je n'avais plus participer au
déplacement officiel du président de la
république que je n'allais plus
participer à enfin je n'ai pu être à
j'avais pu avoir les mêmes activités
dont je les prie très mal c'était déjà
vécu ça comme une humiliation si moi
j'avais déjà une première sanction et on
m'a expliqué que j'avais pu le faire et
ça a été verbal et non pas notifié par
écrit alors la rétrogradation a été le
dessus de manière verbale exactement en
fait on m'a enlevé des missions pour
tout vous dire pour me rajouter d'autres